[Musique]
les anniversaires fonction il ya sept
ans
et bravo à ceux gagnés ce premier petit
jo les amis aujourd'hui nous sommes en
islande il ya karachi juste là car h les
gens me connaissent ils étaient là pour
un voyage de 10 millions alors j'ai
cherché aussi si friands j'ai cherché à
lui donc et lamine faye apollo qui est
aussi là pour un voyage de 10 millions
et la somme le quai la barre regarder il
est très très beau c'est notre guide
regardez bien pourquoi on est là
regardez bien ces tensions
souvenez vous on avait fait une première
collaboration avec honor une vidéo
qashqai gens parlent beaucoup parce
qu'elle vous a beaucoup plu et moi aussi
ça m'a beaucoup plus tôt et cette vidéo
qu'est ce qu'elle doit livrer un peu
plus tard en fin d'année mais à
l'occasion de la sortie du honneur 8,6
que j'ai ici présents sous la main on
leur a proposé d'aller en islande pour
prendre des très belles photos avec le
téléphone et surtout on a un programme
de malades on a des activités vraiment
intense aujourd'hui on a un planning
cool on commence par quoi ils voir une
ancienne chambre magmatique un volcan
quand on va partir sur la côte sud et on
va aller premièrement dans le bordeaux
et ensuite on va les champs de classe en
vrai sur un clash est d'accord c'est
quoi le mordor c'est la plaine qui
t'amène ou un glacier et ensuite on aura
passé toute la journée au froid et
membres entrés dans les sources d'eau
chaude et islande
ah oui j'ai vu des photos de sa légende
en des sources il fait froid dehors mais
dans l'hôtel bien les amis c'est i park
art digne de marchandises vers le volcan
g3 j'en ai jamais vu de ma vie à part
quand j'avais 8 ans et je me souviens le
moniteur s'était moqué de monde famille
parce qu'il me dit que ça venait
sûrement d'un en scène qui est un
clochard
d'où le nom je m'appelais hochart je
vous jure c'est une vraie anecdotes
allez c'est parti on y va
[Musique]
amis nous nous apprêtons à commencer le
début de ce fait les conditions
météorologiques sont désastreuses ya du
brouillard
il pleut la caméra on peut assortir à
plus de trois minutes il ya de l'abus et
où il goûte son objectif et je vais
arrêter de me plaindre dès maintenant
pour qui fait cette journée en compagnie
de pedro qui ajustait monde
on va l'atteindre ce volcan on va
l'attendre
[Musique]
juste en bas pour la blague juste gardé
ses organes de la ont aussi soumis la
sincère league on va plus tarder à s'en
tirant sans toi moi pareil je te vends
pas serein qui m'ont appuyé sur des
trucs comme ça même si je n'ai pas lu
mais là on va avoir besoin à 529
[Musique]
mais qu il ya une goutte frère allait
tomber de tout en haut du volcan elle
m'a fait très mal à la limite on est
dans un volcan on en parle partout il ya
très longtemps c'est pas nous mais de la
lave qui se trouvait dans cette chambre
magmatique
habituellement elle s'effondre après
l'éruption du volcan mais comme là et
les 450 mètres sous terre elle est resté
bien en place si on regarde bien on peu
voir pas mal de trous dans les parois
par lesquels la lave s'est faufilé
jusqu'au sommet du volcan
je suis scotché devant ce qui m'entoure
c'est tellement beau ça va donner une
belle photo
[Musique]
et ben [ __ ] les amis on s'est régalé
non non mais répondait en écho à oser
dire qu'on a notre petite photo est
tellement opaque on ne sait pas ce que
c'est celle ci vaut ça ressemble à corps
un menhir de l'époque néolithique arrête
virgules
non c'est un menhir de l'époque
néolithique je te rappelle qu'au nord ne
validerons pas ce que tu dis non il est
temps de nous diriger vers une prochaine
destination mais sera pour voir cette
fois un glacier immense il a fait encore
plus froid on va traverser la zone qui
s'appelle le mordor sa mère ne l'a dit
tout à l'heure pendant la petite soupe
qui nous devons faire qui nous mais bien
les qualités mais est un peu moins bien
franchement je quitte cette aventure ce
temps là c'est faux bon là c'est du
matos de la merde allez on y va
j'aurais préféré un soleil à l'aide
on est équipé pour monter longages je
suis content parce qu'on a un piolet on
va dire que c'est une pioche et avant ce
jour-là ce projet cet instrument c'était
dans minecraft et dans fahrenheit
on a aussi une paire de chaussures avec
des crampons pour pas qu'on glisse comme
des cons parce que basset de la glace on
va vraiment être un [ __ ] de glaciers
et la petite nouvelle très triste c'est
qu'en fait avant le glacier il ya dix
ans tous là où il ya de l'eau basse et
du glacier c'est très triste dérèglement
climatique bien sûr en est la cause et
c'est un peu triste voilà ces badauds ya
plus tout le monde positif est cool
c'est bon ça va bien j'adore ce bruit
alors pourquoi y'a du noir sur le glace
il en fait il s'agit des centres dans
votre camp qui est entré en éruption en
1918 ça fait cent ans que son
anniversaire hier peut-être qu'on peut
lui chanter joyeux jamais
hier c'est
joyeux anniversaire joyeux et très
diverses et de reconstruction ya cent
ans
joyeux anniversaire
c'est sûr ça bouge et on va commencer à
évoluer progressivement vers le haut du
glacier on est équipé pour on est un peu
comme spider man attention démonstration
pour les amis je prends le relais avec
lego pro pourquoi parce qu'il pleut
énormément du dock et en pls il ne peut
ni faire de drones parce qu'il pleut et
d'y sortir la caméra parce qu'elle aussi
elle craint la pluie alors regarder le
visage d'un homme frustré c'est
maintenant aux repas les larmes parce
que je la plus musclée
on est sur un bloc de glace de 590
mètres carrés rien que ça ces dix
dernières années il a perdu une dizaine
de mètres de hauteur et sa longueur à
dix minutes plusieurs kilomètres samedi
va nous dire quelque chose de frappant
un sein c'est ce qu'on appelle un moulin
ok l'eau s'infiltre dans glaciers pas ce
qui se passe et que si par malheur qui
devait tomber là dedans que reste bloqué
dedans tu encore fait bouchons et l'eau
montrent assez aurait donc à tout moment
s'il a par exemple la polo et je fais ça
et peut mourir
pourquoi tu peur les hommes comme je
trouve qu'on se rend pas compte à quel
point c'est grave ce qui se passe tant
qu'on n'a pas vu quelque chose d'aussi
gros j'espère vraiment qu'on se
réveillera avant qu'il soit trop tard et
qu'on pourra réparer nos bêtises parce
que là ça devient vraiment urgent
[Musique]
hier c'était une blague prévu oui en
fait montagne la ccva ça du tout
on a trouvé un moulin vous savez ces
fameux trou lesquels faut pas tomber ben
non on va tomber dedans volontairement
hockey dans ces fonds aura juste des
sommes un peu pour voir à quoi ça
ressemble dégager une photo pas bégueule
en fait on dirait pas si c'est une vue
aérienne très éloignées c'est une vue de
très près parce que finalement
finalement est la glace bleue ni comment
servent aux incroyables l'infiniment
petit correspond à l'infiniment grand
cette photo en est la preuve allez je
file d'un glacier à toutes les guerres
blog c'est parfois qu'on appelle bourg
[Musique]
bon du coup vu le temps là en gros on
est dans un nuage est ce qu'on peut dire
on a la tête dans les nuages sans parler
de la salle d'arcade parisienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh non on est en dépression nous allons
maintenant se diriger vers une troisième
et dernière activité les gars ça va être
très détente que vous avez beau maillot
oui allez c'est parti ça dégage à se
dégage ça dégage
[Musique]
l'ugta a 22 ans il passe plus de six
heures par jour sur chatroulette y la
pluie 200 contacts msn est une pratique
le jumpstyle nocturne trois fois par
semaine on va aller dans une source
d'eau chaude naturelle ici en islande
yamnaine qui très grande très belle
c'est celle on va actuellement on va
finir la journée là bas après avoir
marché aussi longtemps ça va nous faire
du bien aux muscles et au corps en plus
actuellement il ya le match
france-allemagne là on a raté tout le
match il reste 10 minutes et je veux
qu'on se mettre dans mes combats un peu
tu vois à l'aise j'ai fait pas les
manchettes de la lumière
[Musique]
ils m'ont fait à temps passez vous fait
un sketch en maintenant il me faut
attendre mais il fait comme la 2 3 2 3
en bref sur deux journées que c'est ça
qui est bien c'est la souffrance avant
le plaisir intense et plaisir intense et
pour voir un amour naissant
les mecs plus rien n'a d'importance est
plus que moi et c'est tout bon est ce
que tu penses que l'équipe de france se
doute qu'un mec regarde le match dans
ces conditions ça c'est 2018 ça c'est
mon plus beau coup on est bien on sait
que tu vas mettre la caméra ici que je
vais vous filmez votre année et vous
allez attendre trente secondes icéo greg
boulot ici je vous attendais a duré plus
longtemps
voilà une bien plus je parle tandis
qu'eminem ray park et inflige je vais te
coup les mecs cool et moi quand j'te
couleurs sont celles où les amis petits
secrets sortent de leur trajet 50 de la
facture et que tu dois les derniers
gagnent 10 au nord c au nord et nous on
va nous
ce n'est pas du tout plus de rester
allez bonne à boire le respect total
et ça dégage et remet son petit il remet
son titre en jeu le débit ne le fait pas
n'importe quoi dans la vie c'est terminé
de la journaliste lors de ces 24 heures
en islande ses voyages le plus court de
toute ma vie je n'étais jamais venu à ce
que c'était génial
oui est ce que les conditions
météorologiques ne sont détruites oui on
a découvert en live le temps en islande
c'est un délire comme ça change très
très vite à part ça on a vu de belles
choses aillent en plus la france est là
quoi
bah oui et attendez il faut aussi que
montre la dernière photo on n'a pas
montré la voici en photo avec cette tête
dans la fumée passive est une des
différentes ceseda marchera pas voilà on
a fait nos trois photos les gars on va
en islande pour faire trouve souvent des
comptes de ça la chance qu'on a c'est
incroyable c'était génial je suis un peu
triste de rentrer et surtout je suis
très triste parce qu'on n'a pas pu faire
jusqu'au bout les au niveau de la
réalisation de la vidéo on n'a pas pu
faire énormément de drones dès qu'ils
pouvaient plus on sortait devront se
dépêcher de faire des plans mais il se
mettait à pleuvoir les capteurs est bipé
de partout et on est en panique sur le
glacier merci au nord va remercier les
gens qui nous envoyer en islande c'était
trop cool ces petits voyages on se
retrouve très vite dans une prochaine
vidéo et n'oubliez pas l'infiniment
petit ressemble beaucoup à l'infiniment
grand et plus longtemps les femmes non
[Musique]